The joe rogan experience.
You know,
I was a incompetence shoot a movie and I'm 18 years old,
19 years old.
Brad Pitt's in the movie,
we played runners together as movie called across the tracks.
So I think you know,
when you're 18 you're Tufts.
So I'm on my porch,
some Jivan around Compton stop at a hamburger and fries to stop at a hamburger
joint.
This in 1988 the crack whores,
no crack wars are going on.
You would drive it around Compton in a Porsche in 1988 looking like me,
Waa.
This is Nwa days,
right?
Yeah.
So you're 18 you'll hear your 12 I look like I'm 14 yet.
And you step out of a bad ass fucking car,
but a bad ass burgers,
bitch start ordering cheeseburger.
And this is really nice.
Dude comes up to me,
black guy and he's like,
you know what's up Ricky?
Silver spoons.
Love it,
man.
Love you.
And he's really nice.
Black people have always loved me.
I don't know why,
but they really dug silver spoons.
So anyway,
so we're talking a few minutes later I go back to [inaudible] was the original
MTV cribs.
I go to back to check it out.
I go back to check on my car and there's three guys in my car in your car and
like I didn't turn the alarm on.
My doors are open,
my hatches open,
and they're pulling that CD change.
Remember back in the day that you had like an eight?
Yes.
CD Changer.
So they're ripped that out.
Oh my God.
Now the working on my blog,
punk on my radio screwdrivers and so I ran over and they were like cracked out
people and I said,
well get out of my car.
Get Out of my car.
Getting that.
They need to look at me.
They're like glanced at me and just went back to work.
What?
Wow.
Literally that was,
oh my God,
there was nothing I could do.
What the fuck was going through your head?
You were helpless.
You were how old?
18 years old.
And they're ripping my blop on guy with their,
with their screen.
You don't have a cell phone back to any of that.
And then your page,
somebody?
No,
the guy that was,
I was in line with ordering hamburger.
Cheeseburger.
Really Nice Guy.
He comes around the corner and he sees my predicament and he goes,
Ricky,
what's going on and go,
these guys are ripping my stuff off.
And he goes,
okay,
I'll help you.
Hold on.
And I watched him go to his truck and he owe his car and he opens the trunk and
he pulls out a shotgun this big wow with a pistol grip and he runs up to my car
and he pointed at the guys in my car and he says,
gather motherfucker car.
I'm going to kill you.
And all those guys got right out of my car,
man.
Wow.
Oh my God.
I got my car.
And he said,
Ricky,
you gotta get out of here.
You don't belong around here.
That was on youtube.
See,
that's the kind of shit that needs to be on youtube.
Wow.
I never stepped foot off the set again and Compton,
oh my God.
Holy Shit.
So they just went right back to work.
Yeah.
Just looked at me and went back to it.
Right.
But that one got to sit my ass,
man.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hello.
Hello.